yeah small children if you're watching
don't try this at home
[Music]
level one a level two
I could try level to work my way up
there's so many different ways okay let
me see how difficult this is oh it's
it's even faster than normal
[Music]
let's weaker than normal though oh it
took my cream look at these plans
they're so majestic ah look at those
pawns he used one second
they used one second so it's much weaker
in this in this format but it's much
faster - hmm no those pawns were
magnificent
like Queen h5 was terrible I should just
take the Knights rematch I can't move
this fast again magnificent pawns triple
pawns ah these pawns I was so bad all
those discovered checked you okay oh
shout out to gory and chess we'd welcome
people okay I keep saving stuff oh stop
it lost all my pieces
oh yeah I need to pre move but I can't
pre move because it's so fast I feel
like that first game was my closest to
[Music]
me oh that's difficult so I could try
scholars means nevermind
oh it meted me again okay I'll do a few
more this is this is really difficult I
don't know what I did there oh that's
actually not a bad idea let's try that
though I tried the hippo and it didn't
work
why'd you tell me to do that I tried the
hippo
it's my rook like when I was gonna play
it too I guess
[Music]
oh my gosh that was not good or phanie
it was not a good opening let's choo
failed hippos starfish messes with the
hippo was this
one more hippo Connect for let's go
Connect for again let's go g5 let's go
like a fourth I got for it again it's
just twined around with me oh thanks I'm
also really tilted right now okay play
Stafford gambits every man's my Queens
but it didn't work to figure out its
weakness I thought I was gonna meet it
but it didn't work it's playing all
these dirty moves not under promotion
this is probably the best move - is that
the best move yeah I D it equals night
well the cheater
I can't even report it
level two one minute okay level two one
minutes I feel like this will be easy
cuz it's gonna be slower I'll have more
time and do this to build up my
confidence nope that was a bad move a
slight slip okay this should be pretty
simple
I've lost upon the opponent and tickets
okay I Pete level two pretty easily kind
beat level four or a level eight
let's try level eight so I think level
eight is slower I definitely played
level eight before in this
yeah this pawn structure is kind of
grotesque but I'll try and oh I didn't
mean to Castle queenside I'll try and
make this work that's a good move
I'm already in trouble you can sack
maybe play three first
ooh
I was just playing good moves I resign
man it's not easy try one more game
Rosalina
I'm actually happy with this opening
and before maybe coming ok f4 I like the
closed positions where you don't really
have to worry too much about tactics
just don't have to make sure not to
blunder
let's take with the thing I'm a knight
of five and so applying pressure it's
kind of annoying pressure to like Queen
and b7 any Jade's yeah it's winning
stuff now they're two rooks for Queen
and bunch of pawns what what is this
good move
this brutal
it's very brutal I got it down to 16
seconds let's do one more and then I'll
probably retire I'll make it till
midnight
so the first London game I just messed
up play this move doesn't that e7 I'm
feeling very comfortable here I have a
nice time advantage as long as it
doesn't start like just blitzing out
moves I should be okay it's going for
the space of expansion
the e4
a risky move but okay I have some attack
now
how what to do though
am I not meeting it's so close yet so
far no I got [ __ ] it's so sad
it felt like I was very close to winning
here I'm just losing according to
stockfish a book let's go back was it
really that bad
it was bad the whole time while like
here it seems very couple eggs for the
road I tried yeah I could I could do
like a whole match maybe I'll do a match
at some point it's been rough